the European Union while economically
united great differences remain Paris
Berlin Warsaw they all defined their own
social standards for example when it
comes to weekly working hours the French
work only 35 hours per week while
Germans poles and other EU member states
have far longer working weeks now the
French government wants to end this
employee friendly rule but labor unions
are putting up a bitter fight even
though the country desperately needs
reforms in order to create jobs because
the French unemployment rate is higher
than 10% in Germany only 6.4 percent are
unemployed while 7.5 percent of poles
are out of work but the poles have the
least to smile about unlike Germany and
France which dedicate a large budget to
Social Welfare to support the unemployed
and needy Poland earmarks just 18
percent of GDP for Social Welfare this
means an unemployed person in Poland
receives just 200 euros per month and
although the cost of living has risen
since Poland joined the EU wages have
not families in particular are
threatened by poverty what about
retirement ages across the EU here too
inequality is rife new retirement ages
are being phased in the French are set
to retire at 62 the poles and Germans at
67
so Germans work longer than the French
do does this make German pensions higher
as well no it doesn't French pensions
are higher than German pensions
the German government has decided that
everyone must work longer for the
pension system to be properly financed
the EU is drifting apart the dream of an
EU United over social standards is
slowly fading away